From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Today is December 13th, 2015. This is David Cline from the History Department and Virginia Tech,
and also working with the Southern Oral History Program at the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill.
I'm here for the Civil Rights History Project of the Library of Congress,
the Smithsonian's National Museum of African American History and Culture and the Southern Oral History Program.
And very honored to be here today with Joseph and Embry Howell and what I would ask you to do,
oh, one note, I want to acknowledge a couple of other people in the room before I have you introduce yourselves.
So we have John Bishop from Media Generation behind the camera and also helping us out today is Guhashankar from the Library of Congress.
So now what I would ask you to do is, the only time I'm going to script you at all today is to ask you to use a full sentence to introduce yourself.
Each of you, I am more my name is, and introduce yourself. And then what we're going to do is just have a conversation.
We'll talk a bit about each of your childhoods and sort of what may have informed you leading up to involvement later in the movement,
and then we'll talk about your activity. So whoever wants to go first.
Oh, my name is Joe Howell.
And I'm Embry Howell.
Okay. And Emory, let me start with you if you could tell us a little bit about where and when you were born,
and I'll ask you some questions about your child.
Okay. I was born in 1945 in Bethesda, Maryland near here at suburban hospital.
My father had the war had just ended, and my father was just leaving his assignment in the Navy.
He actually, he had already gone back to where my family lived in Bristol, Virginia at that time,
and my mother stayed here to have the baby.
And so where were you raised then?
So I was raised for five years in Bristol, and then my family moved to Davidson, North Carolina,
where my father was treasurer of the college and ultimately president of the college.
So I grew up in a very idyllic setting right on the college campus.
And could you tell me a little bit about what your family was like,
the values that you were raised with, sort of, you know, the benefit of hindsight and looking back,
but you obviously got involved in the Civil Rights Movement.
Can you see values that were instilled with you or things that you were perhaps, you know, reacting to in North Carolina?
Yeah. Well, I'm from Southern Stock.
We both are. My parents were both born and raised in Georgia.
My father in North Georgia near Atlanta, and my mother in South Georgia, really the deep South.
But they both came from what I would credit my values from very highly educated people for the South.
In fact, both of my grandmother's went to college, which is very unusual for women at that time, as well as my grandfather's.
And that level of education goes back into the 19th century as well.
So my mother went to New York and basically went to communist meetings sometimes in the 30s and was very connected to the radicalization in the 30s.
Not my father. My father was a more traditional person, but they were very accepting.
My father and his presidency was influential in integrating Davidson.
So the first black students who came were from Africa.
And that was, you know, I mean, it's hard to believe that that wasn't until.
Was that during the time you were there? 63.
The very first black students, and they started with African students.
And then I don't know when the first African American students came to Davidson, but it's amazing to think that when I was a child, and I went to thoroughly segregated schools.
But it was a little southern town, and my friends lived across the tracks, and their parents worked in the mills in town.
And I had very close friends there. So I would cross the tracks to go play with friends, and my mother, I wouldn't say it was her idea, but she didn't discourage that.
So I'd say from very early years I learned that all people have value and should be treated with dignity.
So, and most people were quite religious in that era, went to church, and so it was perhaps a cheering church, and was not integrated.
But you got the values of love and acceptance, I think, from that as well.
Did they have race relations Sunday at that point in the church?
No, there was nothing like that. There was no real effort reaching across.
But that started a little bit, you know, I'd say, just starting when the beginnings of the Civil Rights Movement in the early 60s, but I can't recall anything like that happening much in Davidson, Joe may [have known], because he was a student there, and he was a student radical there.
But what was interesting was that we were in Southwest Georgia, which will come up later, and my grandmother, my mother was raised just a few miles from where we lived.
And so, you know, there we were back in Southwest Georgia where she grew up, and she was quite accepting of us doing what we did.
I hope definitely ask about that.
Yeah, but Joe, if I could turn to you for a moment, and have you tell us a little bit about where you were born and raised?
So, yeah, I was born in 1942 in Nashville, Tennessee, and I grew up in a suburb of Nashville called Belle Meade, which was the quote, elite neighborhood.
My father was ended up being a president of a bank, and his father was the president of a bank, and it was understood that I would probably be a banker.
And I went to Montgomery Bell Academy, which was a elite prep school, all boys.
And this was part of the Nashville elite of a very heavy emphasis on some of the social aspects, social order.
And what affected my life early on was having polio, 1952, polio, 1952, Warm Springs.
I was moderately paralyzed. I spent six months in polio, 1952, Warm Springs, and I was, I missed two years of school, at homebound teacher, but I was not a part of the school of those years with growing up into very important ages of 10 and 12.
And that gave me a sensitivity for people who were suffering. I never felt sorry for myself really, in that sense of being suffering, but I felt, I felt an empathy for people that I think I probably would not have felt otherwise.
And if I had not had that experience, it's quite probable I never would have ended up getting involved in this in the Civil Rights Movement.
So that was sort of the foundations, but I did not know growing.
You remember making those kind of connections, even that, you know, or just something that you grabbed?
I think I look back on it, it just sort of happened. I was always sort of a bleeding heart. It wasn't just Civil Rights, but I had a soft spot in my heart.
I was bringing turkeys to poor people in high school and feeling ash. How can people live in such conditions in an area where there's such affluence?
So that, I think that was a piece of it. And my parents were both very religious and very involved in the church, my mother, especially.
And I think there were religious values, I think they were important as well. We were Episcopalians, and our church was near Vanderbilt, and it was a somewhat diverse congregation.
And then, and you went to Davidson?
I went to Davidson.
And that's where you went?
My senior year, after I'd gotten involved in Civil Rights Movement, we were getting to that probably in a minute, but my senior year, in Embry at that point was a mere child.
I looked back on it, and I can't believe it was so young, but it was around my old college, which was moved out of town.
Although, I think briefly we had met once before, but that's when we started dating.
We were in a Mustang year at Davidson.
You dated President's daughter?
The President's daughter.
And I was the controversial student on campus.
So tell them about student activism at Davidson in that period.
Well, yeah, I was going to get it. I meant to mention in Nashville, I did not know in Nashville what was going on at the time in 1962, in 1963, and even earlier than that.
That's where a lot of the early civil rights movement was taking place.
And the planning of it all, the early sit-ins were planned in Nashville.
Nashville was supposed to be the first spot, but they were preempted by Greensboro, and NC A&T, and so on.
But Davidson was aware of that.
My freshman year, my sophomore year, where other cities, a few students participated, was very controversial.
And then, and then I became sort of a big man on campus.
I see a year I was president of the YMCA, which reported some bizarre reason.
It was an important institution. Then at Davidson.
And I was a president of ODK, which gave me a lot of social standing with a leadership fraternity.
And I was in a fraternity. In fact, I was about as conformist.
You could find out all the things you're supposed to do there.
But the segregation piece was a sense, even a no-brainer, well, was a no-brainer, even then, in terms of the injustice.
I'm even growing up, where this just doesn't make any sense.
I remember having a playmate, who was named Frederick, who was my age, and we played together until a seven or eight years old.
And at a certain point, my mother said, well, you and Frederick aren't going to play together anymore.
And I was a black kid, obviously, who was the nephew of our housekeeper.
And I just didn't understand. So someday, someday, well, you will understand.
And so I went to, I remember going to a YMCA camp with a lot of kids.
There were white kids from the other side of the tracks.
There would be lower, quote, unquote, lower class working class white kids.
Very much anti, anti black folks, which rub me, or at least my sensitivities, etc.
So when you get to Davis, all this stuff is starting to happen.
And we went to a conference in Bryn Mawr, called the Third Great American Revolution.
It was mainly East Coast colleges. It was put on by Haverford and Bryn Mawr.
And it just happened to go there with a handful of other Davidson students.
I was the only senior. And all the leaders were there.
I mean, CORE represented; SNCC as SCLC was there.
And the headguys weren't there. The lieutenants were.
This is what you're again?
This was the spring of 1964.
In those days, this was sort of right in the middle of the Civil Rights Movement.
In those days, the message was clear. The audience, the participants were almost all white.
And they were almost Ivy League, Presbyte just schools.
Davidson was the only Southern school I think that was represented.
And says, don't sit on the sidelines. Get involved.
I mean, you can't be neutral in this.
So we said, you know, we ought to do something.
And also, I did have one experience that day.
This was right before Freedom Summer.
That's right. This was going to go free to summer of 1964.
And I'd remembered the Freedom Riders had come through Davidson my sophomore year.
And I sat in on a very small group of people.
I remember the student Union Theological Seminary. There weren't many people describing their experiences of cattle prodders and being spat upon by these.
irate white people. And I just couldn't believe this was happening in our country.
But before we, it was about a five hour six hour drive to Davidson.
And before we actually arrived at Davidson, which was late in the evening,
we'd come up with a plan. We were going to do something.
We had us let us stand up. And I was the logical figurehead.
I mean, I was not an activist. And I didn't see myself as a revolutionary.
But it just seemed like the right thing to do. So what are we going to do?
So we said, we're going to organize on March.
This is a very, this was the same time that the March of,
this is, follow the March on Washington, which was in 1963.
This is the spring of 1964.
We're going to have the March on Charlotte.
Somebody said, wait a minute. Charlotte is, you know,
it's not Jackson, Mississippi or Birmingham, Alabama.
They actually have fairly progressive racial policies.
These, these, they felt they were.
This maybe it's the March in Charlotte.
But what we're going to do is collect signatures for people supporting the Civil Rights Act of 1964.
At that point of 1964. And then we're going to mail the signatures to President Johnston.
So we, and we, and we were going to partner with all the schools in the area that we could find.
But predominantly by schools, Barber-Scotia, Johnson C. Smith,
which was really the host school and several others.
And I was the, ended up being the figurehead in this thing in this event.
And it was quite controversial, as you can imagine.
And the fact that I wasn't doing it.
Way till we get the bird clock.
I don't always go off at the same time.
I mean, looking back on it, it seems about as innocuous as you can get.
All you're doing is saying you're supporting the Civil Rights Act of 1964.
But it was obviously had a symbolic meaning that went beyond that.
And Davidson was the sleepy school safe places in your child.
So I got, I knew that I would get a telephone call.
I would get some pressure at some point.
And sure enough, a few days before the March was going to start.
I got a call from the president of Davidson College, and D. Grier Martin.
Who had a daughter named me and Embry Martin.
I did not know at the time.
And inviting me into his house.
I mean, it was like eight o'clock at night in his wife, Louis,
greeting me at the door.
And it's great.
It'll be with you in just a second when in the study.
And he, when we sat down, he said, Joe, I just have to tell you that there's a lot of pressure on me
from the Board of Trustees and from the mayor of Charlotte to ask you to just abandon this, that's how I do it.
Now, I have to also say that I can't force you to do anything.
You can do what you want to do.
You were very careful to point that out the outset.
But he said the racial relations in Charlotte have actually been pretty good.
And the feeling is it will create an image of the city that will do more harm and good
because it will distort the picture.
And then you've already made your point.
So why don't you just abandon it and move on.
But you don't have to.
And I could get a thought of a hint of a slight net a wink.
But I had the sense that he was actually supporting this.
And it turns out behind the scenes he was doing a lot to make integration happen.
And Davidson, which had already started with [the] foreign students.
And then a few years later, two or three years later, the American students were at Davidson as well, American Black students.
So we did the March and got a lot of coverage.
One of ending and getting in the wire services picked it up.
And the headlines of the conservative newspaper in Nashville had banker's son leads rights March.
So that got everybody's attention.
Joseph T. Howell III, which is me, the son of Joseph T. Howell Jr., president of Nashville City Banks,
is involved in a leader of this March in Charlotte.
So my parents were.
Their friends, they were part of the Nashville elite cocktail party set.
And people would come up and do them.
And they would say, well, Carol and Joe, it's not your fault.
I mean, these things do happen.
And just don't blame yourself for it.
And my parents were actually very supportive.
And never, I never got any feedback.
And finally, my mother just came out and just felt tired of this happening and say, look, we're very proud of what our son has done.
And I've been going back to Nashville shortly after that.
I was a bit of a pariah.
My best friend's mother, when I went to see my best friend, who to play our usual game of Frisbee,
met me at the door and said, you were no longer welcome in this house.
You are discredit to your race into this community.
And I never want to see.
I didn't hurt my relationship with my good friend.
But it was a real, that was a, and I feel sorry for her, really.
I mean, they were, I never took that personally at all.
I felt that she was a product of her time and culture.
And it was then a thought of a straight jacket, as were a lot of people in those days.
Because it was a controversial times.
So I've just to finish this up.
And in a sense, it could have been over.
But we kept involved.
One of, one relationship that was established was with Allard Lowenstein.
And Al was at UNC State teaching history.
He would send me stuff.
And he would be on the back of a test.
Or he would send me special delivery envelope, not a dorm.
And I said, it's a mailman to be searching around the dorm for me to be a special delivery envelope
with a test.
And when the back of the test be scribbled,
something like, give me a call, Al, something like that.
So we got to know Al became almost Allard Lowenstein.
Groupies, of course, he was involved in the dump Johnson movement,
very close to Kennedy family, and a real progressive, brilliant guy, very interesting guy.
Did he just become aware of what we were doing?
Yeah, he was just going to wear me, said this, I'll just give one of the people I want to recruit.
And we became friends with him and his wife Jenny.
And when we moved to Washington, he was actually in our house when our first child was born.
He was staying, and it was sleeping on our sofa bed.
And that helped in a way when I got to Union Theological Seminary, which we'll talk, I'm sure, talking about in a minute,
the Loenstein connection, everybody seemed to know Allard Lowenstein.
And the movement, as he had called it, and we would all go to his apartment house
and wait for him to show up two hours after he was supposed to with 50 other people.
He was for those watching us who don't know about Loenstein,
and 50 tell us just a little bit about him.
Well, he went to University of North Carolina and became the leader of the,
he was the president of the National Student Association at the time,
and he went to Yale Law School, and was a movement guy progressive.
And Eleanor Roosevelt was one of his, he rose very close to her.
And he was like a pied piper, he had taught his dancer, and he had taught at Yale, I think, for a while.
And everywhere that he taught, students gravitated to him because he was so smart,
and he was such a charismatic figure.
And eventually got elected to Congress before they germinated his district,
and then he didn't get elected, but ran again several times,
and then was tragically killed, assassinated, really by a former student who was mentally ill, named Dennis Sweeney.
And the student who was mentally ill was the roommate of a good friend of ours at Union Theological Seminary,
who became a pretty famous civil liberties lawyer, lives in Portland, matter of fact.
So, all this sort of interconnections.
So when did you start thinking about going on to Seminari?
Well, I got a Rockefeller Fellowship, as many people,
and which at the time was funded by the Rockefeller Foundation,
to send people to Seminari who didn't have any idea what they wanted to do with their lives,
and maybe some of them went in up in the church.
And so, and I chose Union Theological Seminary because it was in New York City,
and it was a progressive institution in Paul Tillich, and Reinhold Niebuhr had been there,
it was probably the premier Protestant theological seminary in the world in those days.
So I thought I'd really made it into the big leagues.
And so I went that one year, and I liked it enough to stay on a second year.
At which point I got somewhat disillusioned, but by the time they were till late to change,
so I took a year out of Union Theological Seminary and worked something called MUST,
a Metropolitan Urban Service Training William (Bill) Webber, had set up at a great year,
and then finished up at Union Theological Seminary.
By that time I was interested in other things.
I was taking as many courses at Columbia Planning School,
City Planning School, I had a job at the City Planning Department in New York,
and then got a, got in Chapel Hill Planning School,
and went to Chapel Hill and got a planning degree. In my life [my career has been...].
Career has been developing affordable housing or senior housing.
And when did you, so you, we got the, the meeting of the families, right?
With, with every father, and when did you first start dating and that gets a marry?
What if that fits into that story?
Well, actually Joe doesn't remember me, but I remember him,
which is kind of interesting to me, but you see I was much younger than Paul.
I was much younger just kid around town, but we actually met,
I, my first memory was being out there playing basketball and meeting you.
I remember that.
You do, okay?
And then I remember going with my father to the Easter Sunrise Service,
and Joe was speaking, because he was like this fascinating character
who was doing these interesting things, you know, much older man.
And then also that you had gone to work at Lower East Side and came and spoke
to the Senior High Fellowship.
Yeah, so yeah, I knew Joe.
And I remember being, I think in my bathrobe and seeing you arrive at the front door
with some kind of petition for daddy about something or other.
Not to get again.
So, you know, I was very familiar with Joe, and then I went off to college.
And, you know, in those days, there were the women's colleges and the men's colleges.
And you would have, you know, fancy dance weekend, and then guys would come for their date.
So, I had another boyfriend, and Joe came along for the weekend.
And so, we began to get to know each other that way, and fell in love.
Then he went off to Union Theological Seminary, and we got married after my sophomore year in college.
And I transferred to Barnard College.
So, we lived right there on campus at Hastings Hall, and I went to Barnard and finished my degree there.
And so, that's how it happened.
Yeah.
And then we both came down to Chapel Hill together to go to grad school.
He went to urban planning school, and I went to public health school.
So, we were in Chapel Hill for a while, but we came up to DC.
Wonderful.
So, let's stay at Union Theological Seminary just for a second, because I wanted to ask you about meeting Charles Sherrod,
who would have been there while you were there soon, and how you ended up going to such a...
Well, it was because of Charles Sherrod.
Like everybody recruited all of us out.
I can't remember.
You probably remember there's like a...
[Sherrod had recruited] dozens of students close to him.
And he was very charismatic, and very much involved in civil rights.
He'd been one of the founders of SNCC.
And his area was Southwest Georgia.
And he would...
People that he thought of...
All of us...
[recruited] like-minded people that might be interested in doing this.
He would approach us on the look of us right in the eyes.
And I'd need your help.
I'd need you down with me in Southwest Georgia.
How could you say no?
And we have no idea what was going on in Southwest Georgia.
And I don't think he really did...
Either he'd been away from it for a while, but he...
I'm still not exactly sure what was...
The method in the madness.
But nonetheless, he recruited us.
And I remember we discussed this.
Something we weren't doing.
People were still getting killed in those days.
It was still making some risk.
But I remember we looked at each other and said, yeah, this is the right thing.
Big adventure together.
And in the US.
And in Portland, it was all, I guess, an adventure.
So we signed up along with some of our good friends like Ed V. Brickialpister.
From Union Theological Seminary, right?
And went down to the summer of 1966.
1966, right?
You sort of said it's already.
You didn't really know what to expect.
But can you tell me about the trip down there?
Well, that's right.
Well, there were two things that predated the actual working in Southwest Georgia.
On this trip, one was the conference we went to.
We were supposed to be trained.
We were just at Wake Forest.
And it was sponsored by something called, gosh, I can't remember.
But it was somewhat radical, Christian, ecumenical, something, an institute.
That's it.
And now that was awful.
I mean, it was thought control, brainwashing, kind of stuff, and so that of rebelled at that point.
I mean, so we didn't get, didn't help us much.
Because it was not just civil rights people, it was always other people that were involved doing other things over the summer.
And they were supposed to radicalize all these young Christians and take over the world with Christianity.
That was a complete nutcase, I thought, [were] all the people involved.
But we did meet some civil rights workers at the time.
And I remember going out and they gave us some advice in terms of you always back in,
so you can into a restaurant or someplace so you can run to the car and get out before they come after you can get a quick getaway.
That's right.
And other things like that.
So we arrived in Southwest Georgia after driving all night at the SNCC office,
which is located in the area of Albany, it says, it's called Harlem.
And which was, in some ways, it was like, many of your home in New York Harlem.
And my recollection is being met by the civil rights guys, black guys, and white t-shirts and blue jeans.
And as we got out of the car, the comment, the first comment that I recall somebody making was, so welcome to Albany.
So we are black panthers.
You are a roosterous, which is the, you're the emblem, that's the, that's the, the, the, the mascot of the Democratic Southern Democratic Party,
white Democratic Party in Lowndes County, Alabama, Alabama, in some place.
Panthers eat roosters.
Go home, whitey, we don't need you.
So I said, oh my goodness.
Here we are.
Wait a minute, what's wrong with this picture? We're coming down here. We're our selfish.
And we're risking our lives.
And this is the, you know, we're not well with the, with open arms.
And so it was quite unsettling, although that quickly, that quickly passed, although that was the sort of introduction that time times are changing.
And what was going on there?
The big story of that, of 1966 in Southwest Georgia was the big fight between John Lewis and Stokely Carmichael.
And all this was going on behind the scenes. Charlie was right in the middle of it.
But the one view, John Lewis views, that integration is the way to go.
You need the white people, especially Southern white people.
I mean, here we were, the only southerners down there, the only married couple.
You need these people. They will, they will, they will play a role.
Will the Stokely Carmichael us, a few wise, yeah, they could play a role.
They played a role in the past.
But we have got to be responsible for our own fate.
We've got to build up the leadership and to have white people involved confuses things at this point in history.
So it wasn't against us personally.
But we had, we had no idea that this was going on.
We didn't know that Charlie was struggling with all this.
And so that, that played out in part in terms of how, where we got placed and what we did in and played out throughout the whole summer.
The split between people who were really gun-ho and really wanted to make a difference.
And yet people, the ambivalence of, felt by many of the grassroots black civil rights workers that saw us as a threat in, as people who's time has come and passed in terms of where the movement was.
It was that summer that Stokely Carmichael Carmichael and Willie Ricks stayed that in name, right?
That's right. He was, I mean, he was almost to the day.
You know, it's interesting, though. I don't remember those statements. They might not, I was treated kind of with kid gloves.
I was an unusual person. This white, southern female. Most of the people had never met anyone like me.
And the guys were always extremely polite and respectful to me. I never was spoken to harshly the entire summer.
So I don't, if I was there, I don't recall it. I'm sure it happened. But I think they talked to Joe that way.
What about your, every year, Georgia roots in an essence, this, I mean, you would never live there, but coming back to a place that was a problem.
I had spent time in Georgia as a child. I think it was actually helpful. [as transcribed].
Because really, we were raised in fairly close proximity to black people and had a fair amount of contact with them.
We liked the same kind of food. We spoke a lot, you know, the same way. And we understood each other well. And I think it allowed us to not necessarily with the civil rights workers because they were often not from there.
But with local people. So I never had any sense of a strangement in that way. Of course, we couldn't relate to the white people in the community.
So if they saw us walking down the street, [a white woman initially stopped to give her a ride, then refused once she realized who Embry was — i.e., a SNCC-affiliated white outsider].
So we never had contact with the white people.
We had a serious infection when I was down there. And I couldn't see the black doctor. I had to go to a white doctor because it was just unheard of.
That was a complete separate. But that was struck me and kind of strange.
I remember when you wanted to get your hair cut. My hair didn't matter because we had that long hair in those days. But they had never cut anybody's hair like that.
Yeah, that's probably one of the best hair cut I've ever.
I did go into the black barbershop. You didn't want to go into the black barbershop. They were very reluctant to do it, but they did.
So tell me about living within the black community, then, and the family that you got to know. And maybe before that, how difficult it was for a family to be found at first for you all to live there?
So that was the big issue. It's what they're going to do with us. In fact, we were married couple.